depuis la guerre de Sécession
au 19e siècle.
Le spécialiste de la politique
américaine, Rafael Jacob,
est avec nous. Bonsoir, Rafael.
Il faut savoir qu'il y a
17 États américains qui
ont adopté des lois
pour restreindre l'accès
au droit de vote aux États-Unis.
Le Texas veut aussi adopter
un projet de Loi en ce sens.
Que faut-il voir
dans cette sortie de Joe Biden?
- Il faut voir une démocratie
qui est malade. Ce n'est pas
normal qu'un président américain
et/ou ressente le besoin, comme
c'est le cas pour Biden, de dire
que la démocratie américaine
était activement menacée. Il
était à Philadelphie
aujourd'hui, le berceau de la
démocratie américaine. Il y a un
an, le président Obama était
également affalé par un grand
discours dans lequel il disait
aussi que la démocratie était
enjeu. Cela fait des mois et des
mois qu'on a une démocratie, la
plus grande démocratie de la
planète qui est ébranlée. Tout
ça, on doit le dire très
clairement : c'est attribuable à
un acteur et c'est le président
qui a été entre Obama et Biden,
c'est-à-dire Trump. Il fait de
la fraude électorale.
- Les projets de lois sont
adoptés dans les différents
états dont je parlais, ça se
passe dans les états
républicains ou en encore la
défaites 30 à la gorge.
- Il y a des incitatifs
politiques pour les candidats
républicains et pour les
législateurs républicains
d'envoyer un signal clair au
leader de facto du parti, c'est-
à-dire Trump. La fraude
électorale massive, il faut
présenter ça. Ce collant exauce,
c'est une crise politique qui
est hallucinante dans laquelle
on a des dizaines de
législateurs démocrates, on voit
ce projet de loi comme une
menace intégrale au droit de
vote de leurs électeurs. Parce
qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres outils
parlementaires pour essayer de
freiner ce projet. On fait les
l'assemblée législative du
deuxième État en importance de
la plus grande des moquettes de
la planète est présentement
paralysée. Le gouverneur de
cette étala appelle à
l'arrestation de ses membres.
- Les élus démocrates qui ont
quitté l'exhaussent pour aller
en exil pour manifester entre
autres et demander au président
Biden, est-ce qu'il peut
vraiment faire quelque chose
concrètement?
- Non. Notamment la réponse est
non, mais c'est un nom encore
plus prononcé il y a à peine un
mois. Dans le dernier mois, on a
eu des décisions majeures de la
cour suprême américaine qui est
venue valider une loi semblable
qui a des différences
importantes avec le projet de
loi texan qui assembla dans la
mesure où elle venait encadrer
de façon plus stricte certaine
pratique pour ce qui est du
droit de vote dans un état très
proche, Arizona. La cour a
ouvert la porte à ce genre de
restrictions. Pour le
gouvernement fédéral, pour
n'importe quel acteur qui
voudrait contester ce nouveau
projet, disons qu'il y a un
obstacle considérable qui a été
ajouté par le plus haut tribunal
du pays.
- Quand on part du recrutement
de vote, ou en adopter ce projet
de loi, dans les états, ça
touche directement la minorité?
- Dans certains cas. Dans le cas
du Texas, il y avait une mesure
qui était particulièrement
controversée. C'est-à-dire qu'on
voulait carrément abroger le
vote par anticipation. Ça
ciblait officieusement les afro-
américain qui avait une
propension à vanter par
anticipation à ce moment-là. On
semble avoir retiré cette clause
la du projet de loi, mais il
demeure extrêmement controverser
à cause que sablé ciblait les
électeurs démocrates.
- Il y a il y a ce dossier qui
est très chaud. Avec
l'assassinat du président
assisté, la politique haïtienne
rattrape Joe Biden. Un dossier
délicat. Est-ce que les États-
Unis ont la responsabilité
d'intervenir?
- Les États-Unis ont une
histoire pour le moins très
troublent avec Haïti. C'est
méconnu du grand public. Si on
remonte à il y a 100 ans, on
pardonne l'assassinat d'un
président, il y avait eu un
également il y a 100 ans suite
auquel les États-Unis avaient
occupé Haïti pendant plus de 15
ans. L'ingérence ou
l'application des États-Unis
était si intense que le
secrétaire adjoint de la marine,
avait déclaré qu'il avait été
lui-même responsable de réécrire
la constitution des étés. Le
coût de l'histoire, c'est que le
secrétaire adjoint se nommait
Franklin et allait devenir 10
ans plus tard sans doute plus
importants président américain.
Au moment où il est devenu
président, les troupes
américaines étaient encore en
Haïti. Disons que les Américains
ont un rôle à jouer pour
rétablir certains pots qu'ils
vont avoir contribués à classer
dans l'histoire haïtienne.
- On note dans des Joe Biden
mentionné qu'il évalue la
possibilité d'en